la première pierre du tram 13 a été
déposée cette ligne de tram actuellement
en travaux relie saint cyr à saint
germain une seconde phase de travaux
prolongera la ligne du tram 13 de saint
germain à achères un projet attendu par
les yvelinois 4 millions de voyageurs
par emprunteront cette ligne qui entrera
en correspondance avec le rer c et les
transilien à l n et u
nous avions vraiment l'impression d'être
abandonnés au niveau du réseau des
transports en commun c'est bien beau
d'avoir tous les transports qui vont
avec ce réseau en étoile que nous
connaissons mais qui passe par le centre
c'est-à-dire paris et de ne pas avoir de
relation de banlieue à banlieue
le tram train circulera de 6h à minuit
en semaine et le samedi et de 6h30 à 22
heures les dimanches et jours fériés
une façon de désengorger les yvelines et
limiter les embouteillages avec une
ligne soucieuse de son environnement
nous avons droit aussi à des transports
écologiques propre silencieux et qui
nous permettent de plus prendre nos
voitures et de plume nous retrouver dans
des embouteillages monstres donc ce
tramway la région la sauver
la porter à bout de bras on n'en finance
plus de la moitié c'est un tramway qui
va permettre de résoudre notamment la
problématique des embouteillages à saint
germain en laye et c'est d'un tramway
qui se poursuivra jusqu à poissy achères
donc il ya aussi une dimension sociale
parce que ça permettra aux habitants de
la vallée de la seine de venir
travailler à saint germain en laye à
versailles à 50 ans niveau la durée du
chantier du tram 13 est estimé à 4 ans
pour une mise en service en 2021